does ukraine have to start to consider
um ceding some land in to the russians
in order to achieve peace
well i think um we
president olensky is doing a fantastic
job he's leading his country
extraordinarily well and they're
fighting with huge determination i think
we can all recognize that um i think
they are now realizing that they're
going to have to
increase their
their operations uh in the east of the
country that's clearly where the
russians are now going to concentrate
their efforts and
it's very good to hear that nato
yesterday
ministers met and agreed to up the
sanctions and many countries bilaterally
are supporting ukraine with more weapons
um their fight is our fight and it's
extremely good that the west is staying
united and supporting ukraine in the way
that it is
always has to be give and take though
doesn't know in order to try to achieve
peace um do you have a view on on the
next region
um
okay unusually i couldn't quite hear
your question could you be kind enough
to say it again yes i said we always
there always has to be give and take
when it comes to try to achieving peace
and i wondered if you did have a view on
the donetsk region of ukraine and what
should happen to it
well this is a difficult one um
it is a fact that many who live in the
donbass region those two provinces
are russian speakers of course they are
and many of them are focused and
oriented towards russia but the fact
remains that that territory is ukrainian
now this is the great dilemma that
president zielenski is going to have to
wrestle with
is he going to insist that every square
kilometer of ukrainian soil remains
ukrainian soil
or is he going to have to accept reality
on the ground that
luhansk and donetsk provinces might
become occupied by the russians and
might have to be seated to russia and
indeed there is this very difficult
issue of the land corridor that the
russians have almost completed achieving
between crimea through mariopol uh into
the donbass region and this i think is
the great dilemma for ukraine it's the
great dilemma for the west do
they compromise and allow those eastern
provinces and that corridor to go to
russia or do they hold out do we hold
out continuing to support ukraine maybe
the west having to up its support uh in
a military sense to ukraine and
insisting that every square kilometer of
ukrainian territory remains ukrainian
that is a huge dilemma and i don't think
that um people have got the answer to
that one yet
and as far as odessa is concerned we
know of course that it's a a port city
incredibly important
to ukraine and we were speaking
to um
yesterday just tobias elwood and he was
saying that we need to um patrol that
the un needs to patrol that region on
behalf of ukraine do you agree
well odessa is extraordinarily important
odessa must remain in ukrainian hands
it'll be their only major port to get
their exports particularly their wheat
grain exports out into the international
sea lanes so that is extraordinarily
important but you raise an interesting
point whether there should be a third
force an intervention at some point in
ukraine um it would be unacceptable to
the russians certainly for it to be a
nato force but it's conceivable there
could be some kind of longer-term
peacekeeping force third force under the
united nations flag
there's a people aren't really talking
about that at the present moment but it
may be that there has to be
some form of policing some form of
um
international objective uh independent
of observation of whatever ceasefire
line eventually is agreed whether it's
in the east whether it's along the
crimea line or wherever it is it's
something that may have to be thought
about in future in order to have some
kind of independent monitoring of what
is going on for the future i understand
that but but what about now my lord what
do you think should be happening in the
black sea now
well i i think the nations the navies of
the world could quite reasonably uh be
patrolling offshore
um and monitoring and at least keeping
under observation the the russian navy
i think the
there was a lot of talk early on about
the russians having an amphibious force
that might come ashore at odessa but uh
i think that the likelihood of that is
now
quite low as they have seen the poor
performance of their troops on the
ground i think they'd be very wary about
risking the highly risky uh concept of
an amphibious operation perhaps coming
ashore at odessa so i think for the
for nato navies neighbors of the world
to monitor what the russians are doing
makes a lot of sense and i'm sure
consideration is being given to that
you were very kindly on our program a
couple of weeks ago when you talked
about what's happening
as far as putin is concerned and you
said that russia's actions weren't far
off genocide where are you today
well i think the war crimes are stacking
up to the point that it looks like a
concerted effort
to reduce the ukrainian population and
that is getting very close to
the definition of of genocide and it's
absolutely right and proper that all
these war crimes are being chronicled
evidence is being gathered
now whether or not we'll ever get to a
position where putin or his senior
generals
whether there's ever the possibility of
putting them in an international court
in an international dock i don't know
but if you think back and other people
have made this parallel before to the
dark days the early dark days of the
bosnian civil war it seemed
inconceivable that milosevic and
kharidich and maladic would find their
way into court but they did
and it became perfectly possible to
trace what had happened on the ground
all the way up to them through this
concept of command responsibility such
that they were convicted i gave evidence
twice in the hague against serb generals
and it can be done so it's absolutely
right that war crimes are recorded
evidence is gathered and this is looking
to me increasingly like genocide that is
plotted from the top and the top
therefore must bear responsibility and
maybe one day even if not in a physical
court in the court of history be
condemned
we know that uh my lord that you've
passed on your philanthropy to your son
and he does a lot of charity work
particularly with ukraine and of course
afghanistan as well i wonder what your
view is on what we're doing
up to now to bring ukrainian nationals
into the united kingdom i think i read
something this morning saying as of last
week it was 500.
well we've got to do more we've got to
do better we've got to act more quickly
now the british government has set up a
scheme
i've looked into the detail of the
scheme and the scheme is is there but
we've got to be more agile we've got to
move more quickly um
i live in norfolk the editor of the
eastern daily press david polz was in
ukraine on the polish border last week
and made contact with a large number
of refugees who want to come to this
country and there's a team out there
helping them do the paperwork and get
here but we should be much more agile
much more quick about it
in order to get those people who are
traumatized
to places of safety and welcome them to
this country um the government
has put a scheme in place but they've
got to
fire it up they've got to speed it up
they've got to do better we owe it to
those people who have become victims and
survivors of that war that war which the
ukrainians are fighting but they're
fighting it on behalf of all of us for
freedom and the rule of law we've got to
do better we've got to move more quickly
to help more people
okay thank you thanks a lot